if Trump runs again obviously which he's
already declared don't you think he's
rooting for Biden to run against him
meaning that there's nothing speaking of
juxtaposition the last thing that Trump
wants is a young fresh Gavin Newsom just
like the last thing a Biden wants is a
young fresh Ron DeSantis like what would
be more alarming and shocking than
82 year old uh Joe Biden up on stage
debating young fresh energetic Ron
DeSantis polarity and Duality and
juxtaposition would be crazy same thing
with even a trump and
um
our friend Newsome like don't the two of
them kind of want each other I don't
have my thoughts but I'll let Tom
address it I don't think Joe Biden would
want that I don't think Donald Trump
would care
because if you're a winner and you
believe in yourself you're like
whoever gets in the ring I'm coming and
I think that is what you see
in Donald Trump Donald Trump hasn't won
anything since 2016. yeah but but here's
the question for you here's the question
Brady lost the Super Bowl to Philly did
he stop being a winner he didn't win for
seven eight years he you know the
longest drop Brady had because under Wes
welka West played with him for seven
years they never won a Super Bowl ever
really never never Wes Walker never won
a Super Bowl you know what the Belichick
called Wes Welker one time in the
conversation with them you know who
Wally pip is
Wally pip was at the time the greatest
New York Yankees first baseman and then
he missed one game one time because of a
headache you know who replaced him 2 200
games Lou Geer okay so anyways so so so
meaning Wes Wes Walker was replaced by
Edelman and it was game over it's a very
epic scene everybody has to see when
Belichick pulls up to uh uh what's his
name and says hey do you know who Wally
pip is no he says you may want to look
up a Wally pippers Wally pit missed the
game one time Lou Gehrig took it over
and he says it looks like we just had a
Wally pip moment right now he whispers
it to Wes Welker but going back to it I
want you to think about this think about
the three most painful events you had in
your life you don't need to say publicly
just think about it okay
how quickly did you recover from it
that's the question okay think about the
most painful humiliating moment of your
life and how quickly you recovered from
it
now if you're emotionally there and
you're thinking about that moment
the day they're raiding Mar-A-Lago Trump
is golfing
I want you to actually think about this
so imagine you get a call hey Mr Mr
saucenick they're raiding your place
yeah okay who what do you mean I called
the lawyer call this call that okay all
right four
once again actually emotionally go there
the average person when that happens
cancel the game I gotta go
he's like nah let's finish the game he
loves golf it's not about he loves golf
this isn't about he loves golf you could
love basketball you could be playing a
pickup game you know he could be playing
badminton right saying he's unfazed it
could be it could be anything it's the
fact that
the average person overreacts
and he just moves on and he plays his
game and there isn't any game that
you're gonna play worse and then golf
because it's small little stress levels
the ball is going to travel one way or
another this is why you know guys who
are dealing with the kind of personal
issues they were dealing with and
winning tournaments you sit there and
you're like how the hell can you do that
at the levels that you do
so the point to your question is I don't
care I don't think he cares who he faces
I think he wants thinks he can beat
anybody I didn't tell you he's going to
I said that's his mindset he thinks he
can beat anybody he thinks he is the guy
to beat and uh to be to be even a little
bit more uh specific about it he thinks
somebody else has his job right now that
doesn't deserve to have his job in his
mind that's what he thinks he thinks
this is his job he has to finish this
term and he took that four years away
from him to make America great again
whether the populace believes that or
not that's what he thinks that's what
I'm convinced he thinks
um
when you meet people like that
it takes very few people to understand
who that person is one of the greatest
quotes of all time that I have in my one
of my vision boards if a lion could
speak
the world could not understand them
you can't understand the lion
the average person is impossible to
understand the line
it's not possible to understand why
would Jordan be the way he was why would
a guy who's constantly wanting to win
and wants that to be the way why is
Brady why is Brady still playing can you
imagine this year he goes through a
divorce right after his divorce he goes
on a 3-1 streak what would the average
person do there goes through a divorce
uh Tom Brady has taken uh time off for
personal reasons the average player
would do that didn't happen with Brady
and he finished the season love him or
hate him this is probably the most
dramatic year in his personal life not
career you know deflategate all this
other stuff personal life I think I
finished the season I don't care he had
a bad ending the guy finished the season
there are there are people like that and
trumps in that camp that he likes these
types of things he doesn't hide from it
and I know it's not what a lot of people
want to say because right now what's
most popular is you know trashing
trashing trashing by the way the other
part with this whole thing that's going
on right now with Biden and Trump
they're trying to eliminate two people
okay so if you eliminate two take these
two out
take time take Biden and Trump out of
the equation who becomes president
yeah probably let's play this game so
again take by eliminate Biden and Trump
who's President well the most likely to
in terms of um current playing field
would be Newsom and DeSantis however
if
people keep forgetting about Michelle
Obama okay so now let me get the other
one take Biden out leave Trump in who
becomes president
let me ask the question one more time
take Biden out Trump is able to run they
don't do anything to Trump but Biden is
saying he's not going to run who becomes
president oh I I think Trump would beat
Newsom but he would not beat Michelle
Obama okay so let's take Trump out the
kind of handicap let's take Trump out
Obama Biden runs Trump is not running
who becomes president
wow
like that yes I think there's just such
a yearning in this country for if you're
75 and older thank you for your service
wow peace out okay I think there's such
a yearning whether you're on the left
you're on the right there's such a a a
major advocacy on the left and on
especially on the right to get to Biden
the hell out of there and the same rules
apply to Trump and that's why I think
there's there's like Gavin Newsom has
done nothing in his career he's ruining
California why the hell is he at the top
of this list to run for the Democratic
nominee it's because he looks the part
and they're just grooming someone to
take the place of Biden
for all we know about DeSantis he's done
a way better job than Gavin Newsom but
there's such a yearning in in the
country to be like that's the new guy
and whether Trump wants to step out of
the way or not remains to be seen but
I'll always revisit that people want
these 75
octogenarians out of there well and
DeSantis has his flaws I'm saying if
Biden is pushed or he pushes and he's
the candidate and DeSantis
you know gets the nomination I think the
Sanders can beat
Biden but DeSantis himself is not a
perfect candidate decided DeSantis would
mop the floor with Joe Biden mop the
floor and sadly but true I think Gavin
Newsom would actually beat Donald Trump
oh Gavin Newsome beats Donald Trump I
think so
yes
when you go to Miami this weekend go
with security okay I'll do my best you
just said that because again I'm not a
fighter I'm not a fan of Newsome in the
least I just know how these these have
you seen Democratic operations work so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]